hello I'm CAF I'm Dan we're the slow mo
guys doing a giant blue and June still
such a terrible name photo I regret it
well you've committed now this week it's
based on a video that I was sent tweet a
few times there was a gift that someone
took from a video because that's how the
internet does it these days it was a
giant balloon on a trampoline full of
war popping and showering some kids
underneath so I guess I'm gonna be
representing the kids in this you can
represent to kids
I'll fill a balloon on top and hopefully
you'll get absolutely annihilated by a
tidal wave of will get washed away will
just get washed down okay
but hopefully you won't get crushed
that's a good point I might drown though
but although maybe the weight of the
balloon will push the trampoline great
on to you probably will see ya might
like oh I see why don't we stop stop
filling up I'll get another trampoline
all right it's soaked today okay I'm
gonna take this mic off again alright
oh look at what it's gonna be like
Chinese water torture begin it rolling
good oh yeah you get up to be in a bit
of it there's still some sunshine on me
here and I brushed the toilet then they
will went to one bit just peed on me
I'll do a voice memo under there be
alright oh okay
doing voice memo what's the statistic
say for how a waterproof phone is what
resistant to how much splash resistant
splash resistant would you say this is a
splash yeah it's a very big splash yeah
sure yeah sort of like her you get about
20% of the solar thing if that so how
far down do you think it's gonna get
well I think we can get it down to like
my nose yeah I can we can get it down to
prove that if you're under it then it'll
be about here every time I'm sorry so
try and fall asleep yeah so it's just
like a complete surprise
kitty free toilet she join a snack or
anything yeah what do you want well you
got I love like got some hair for the
hoop stay green ones what kind of
flavors that cheese an onion
cough yeah well she got there on your
end don't tease us
please cheese and onion
well this is a pretty ridiculous ad
we've got right now downs under the
trampoline in Hulu employed Oh balloons
on top
phantom looking under the trampoline
starting to lose my mind into this right
yeah cuz I can't focus on the on the
surface of this not with two eyes anyway
how the springs looking pretty better
Hospital Warren there they I think any
place is leaking is on my knob let's
note you the only paces strip in it
starts to look quite unpleasant under
there no you're right yeah
is it big yet it's big yeah well I don't
make it
well if you die ya think you know what I
think you won't you think so just
touching me now here probably like I
clean e on me
oh god it's pretty big
there's no tree on me here Oh see if I
can make myself some room to breathe Oh
flick crusher mere
what's the most squash you've ever been
in your life well I've bundled at lower
school well bundled at lower school
[Music]
that was severe all right playing it
back looks so weird
oh it's dumping it's like a dunk tank
doesn't even look like water it's just
so solid Oh God oh absolutely
showering it looks like one of those you
know the storm sensations you see it
like in the sea yeah where it's just
like a wall of water I would like to see
that through a trampoline that's in the
ceiling it's like the biggest showerhead
ever yeah I want a showerhead like that
so good would you enjoy that shower like
that if all your showers lasted two
seconds yeah but they were like that
yeah that was an absolutely God can't
you and shower got annihilated there I
kind of you know what wasn't too bad
apart from being crushed I think I want
one of those in my house only just go
into a room push your button and then
that happens to me I mean Consular it's
not fishing you never be late for work
yeah I need a shower I'm done okay
that's great yeah dad want a big one for
hot air as well you be oh you know what
would be good is not telling people but
that's what was happening like oh can I
borrow your shower yeah sure just go in
there actually if you weren't expecting
that you just be knocked on your ass
yeah well that was a great shower shower
to whoever sent us that video back in
the day was probably years ago this
point so I can't remove it was but if
you sent us that clip or that gift will
ever Cheers
we finally got around to shoot
and I surprised you actually see under a
trampoline that's good work it shake
with a phantom decent feel free to
follow us on Twitter
thank you for watching giant balloon in
June now and we'll see you in the next
video